if you have two stars in orbit about
each other
which is a very common thing in the
universe then they're not going to be
the same mass in most cases the one
that's more massive will evolve more
quickly and as it ages and evolves it
will swell up and it will get so large
that its outer surface can come in
contact with the gravitational region of
influence of his partner star the
smaller star becomes a vampire it sucks
the bloated outer layer of gas from its
bigger partner and as the vampire feasts
it burns hotter and hotter turning a
brilliant youthful blue the vampire's
victim is sucked dry reduced to a
lifeless stellar core known by
astronomers as a white dwarf but like
any good horror movie this murderous
tail has a twist
exploding zombies there's all sorts of
stories about zombies what if the dead
could actually come back and take
revenge on the people who killed them
well something similar really does
happen with stars as the blue straggler
ages it swells so much the dead white
dwarf starts to steal some of its gas
back from the vampire the dead star
rises again to become an exploding
zombie
is that material piles up it gets hotter
and hotter and you're basically piling
up tremendous amounts of hydrogen and if
it gets hot enough and the pressure gets
enough basically you have created a
hydrogen bomb the size of a planet that
star explodes
these stars can get revenge once the
zombie explodes it takes out the vampire
that sucked its life away for decades
astronomers have been puzzled by the
number of tiny dead white dwarf stars
they see exploding in the night sky but
here finally could be an explanation our
galaxy is filled with vampires and
exploding zombies what does that say
about the rest of our galaxy a huge
chunk of the stars in our galaxy are
sort of stealing life from their friends
to stay forever young the birth and
death of vampires could be the reason we
see blue stragglers today but amazingly
it could also explain why we are here -
there's no way in this universe to get
life without death you can't possibly
have materials to build planets or
people or anything around us without
supernovae so these vampires and these
zombies well actually there are parents
you and I we could be the result of
these vampire stars transferring gas
back and forth in these binary systems
leading to stellar explosions that blew
out the building blocks of life into the
universe
you
you